welcome everyone thank you for joining
us at navigating spatial biology take
that next step with Leica biosystems our
next presentation for today is
introducing new RNA protein code
detection assays presented by madhura
Nayak and Anushka Dixit my name is Marie
and I will be your moderator for today's
event
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
during the presentation
to ask a question click on the Q a box
located on the bottom of your screen
type your questions and hit submit
the speaker will answer your questions
following the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the Q a box
to let us know that you're experiencing
a problem
please join me in welcoming Madura and
Anushka for a complete biography on our
speakers visit the biography tab on the
left Madura and Anushka over to you
thank you mother
for those of you who are not familiar
with the RNA scope technology it's an NC
to hybridization platform designed for
detecting specific RNA biomarkers
on this slide you can see I have
described the three major assays falling
under the irony scope technology
umbrella for detecting RNA biomarkers
the first is the RNA scope Assi which is
specifically for targets that are over
300 nucleotides in length
this acid is available as a chromogenic
or fluorescent assay and in different
configurations of automated or manual
axes
the second is our base scope acid which
is a specialized assay designed for
targets that are between 50 to 300
nucleotides in length these include your
small molecules like
splice variants axon Exon Junctions
highly homologous sequences and also
point mutations
this is again either single Plex or
duplex as a available uh in automated or
manual platforms and finally our newest
assay is the micro RNA scope assay which
as the name suggests is for targets even
smaller than 50 nucleotides and these
are for targets like microaronas Asos or
S irons and currently this is available
as a single Plex assay in both automated
and manual platform
in addition to our rnas uh detection
assays we've also launched a DNA scope
as the this summer which allows you to
visualize DNA biomarkers
so why is it important for us to look at
RNA biomarkers with a highly precise
tool like RNA scope
in the last few years we have understood
the importance of spatial resolutions
since it allows us to study highly
heterogeneous tissues like the embryo or
the brain or tumor wherein you have
multiple cell types that are constantly
interacting with each other
communicating and Inter determining the
function of the target tissue
tools like RNA scope are highly specific
and allow you to visualize your target
RNA biomaco or Target of Interest with
high sensitivity and specificity at
single cell and single molecule
resolution
and thereby allowing you to elucidate
the heterogeneity of these tissues and
study the cellular interactions
why it's important to study spatial
expression of RNA biomarkers it's even
more important to get a multi-ohmic
analysis of your complex tissues thereby
understanding the dynamic interactions
happening between different cell types
and realizing this we have enabled
combining our RNA scope ish assays with
immunofluorescence or
immunohistrochemistry thereby allowing
detection of your RNA biomarkers in
combination with Target protein
biomarkers
this allows us to visualize Target gene
expression in Target cell
it allows us to identify cellular source
of secreted factors like chemokai and
cytokines growth factors
it also allows us to get a better
spatial
visualization of target cells by looking
at by marking the cell border using a
specific antibody and visualizing gene
expression with single cell resolution
using RNA scope probes
and therefore by combining our risk
group with either Minister chemistry or
amino fluorescence we can Leverage The
Best of proteomic and transcriptomic
approaches with high resolution and
specificity
in the next few slides let's figure out
a few examples of how RNA scope can be
combined with immunoster chemistry or
immunoflorescence for a range of
different applications starting with
examining cell type specific gene
expression
in this particular example they're
studying the expression and role of prdm
12 which is a transcriptional regulator
and its role in
um development of pain sensing neurons
so for this example they used a specific
prdm 12 RNA scope flow and combined it
with three different antibodies to study
which of the subtype of these neurons
were expressing prdm12 and therefore
responsible for the development of these
pain sensing neurons
we observe that when they combined it
with trke a these so they saw a very
strong co-expression of prdm 12 ptrka
while on the other hand
um the correlation was not as strong
when they combined it with either trkc
or trk B antibodies
and this told them that there was the
strong correlation of PRM 12 with the
RKA uh shows that we had M12 is
expressed in almost all of the
nociceptive neurons but the expression
was not as strong in proprioceptive or
mechanoceptive neurons
this revealed that the presence of the
prdm-12 transcription uh regulator in
this trt a positive neurons uh suggested
that it was essential for the
development of these pain sensing
neurons
in this next example
they have used the base scope assay and
base capacity with combination with IFC
to validate a single nuclear RNA
sequencing data here we are studying
multiple sclerosis and trying to
understand the differential cell
populations in Ms brain versus a normal
brain they were able to obtain
postmodern Ms brain and compare it to a
normal brain and study expression of
um different RNA markers
here you can see that they've identified
different sets of
neuronal and non-neuronal populations in
the brain and they see some differential
expression between wild type and ms3 so
they used a few markers specific to
oligodendrocyte populations and studied
their expression
um in this uh control brain versus
um
brain with MS and here you can see with
the base capacity the Dual biscope assay
they were able to identify these
different populations of
oligodendrocytes by using uh
subpopulation specific markers
next they wanted to also identify what
are the different
um populations of cells that are
potentially present in a control brain
versus Ms brain and so we compared a Ms
lesion
um and uh
visualized what they are already seen as
a part of the single nuclear Sikh RNA
sequencing that is that they identified
a hybrid cell called oligodendrocrial
cell having characteristics of both the
oligodendrocyte and the mitochlea and
therefore expressed markers belonging to
both cell types and they confirm this by
doing dual based scope IHC by using cd74
a microbial marker and all they want to
oligo dendrocyte marker
and showed that these two markers which
are specific to different types of cells
were actually co-localizing in this
hybrid oligodendroglial cell and this
cell was present in abundance in the MS
lesion
uh suggesting that this hybrid cell
population could have something to do
with the MS pathology and might
contribute to certain pathological
features associated with um MS
in the next example let's look at how
irony scope can be used in combination
with immunofluorescence to identify
soluble factors and the cell of origin
secreting these soluble factors
this is an example where the researchers
were studying pancreatic cancer
and trying to identify
um
whether
live which is leukocyte inhibitory
Factor had a role to play in progression
of pancreatic cancers
they identified that in patients with
pancreatic cancer there are high levels
of circulating lift in their compared to
normal individuals
similarly they also identified that
presence of lymph mRNA correlates to
decreased disease-free survival in these
patients
what they wanted to identify is how this
lift was actually contributing in growth
and progression of pancreatic cancer
so they used
ra scope in combination with
immunofluorescence to study the
expression of leaf and identify how it
might impact growth of pancreatic cancer
cells
in this image you can see that the
combined immunofluorescence for keratin
19 with that of leaf RNA scope probe and
pgprc or cd45 arniscope probe and you
can see that live and pgprc were present
in the streamer region of this tumor
while keratin 19 expression was as you
can imagine specifically locate or
localized to the tumor cells
suggesting that lift is expressed by uh
potentially by the pancreatic State
cells in the stroma and were ex was
exerting its impact in a more
batifying fashion to promote growth of
pancreatic cancer cells
let's look at another example of how
RNA scope is combined with IHC to
identify specific population of immune
cells in this paper that was published
in nature medicine these researchers
were treating these researchers with
treating a melanoma patient with
anti-pedian therapy and this patient
um
unfortunately
reacted adversely and led to
Encephalitis in this patient which was
ultimately fatal but these researchers
are interested in understanding which
immune cell populations were responsible
for inducing Encephalitis in this
patient so they performed a TCR
sequencing on this inflamed brain tissue
and identified
um
sequence that was most frequently
occurring and perform and designed a
specific baseco Pro against this TCR
sequence they then localized the
sequence with uh CD4 and cd8 antibodies
to identify which type of T cells were
present in this encephalized brain
and
surprisingly they were able to show that
this TCR sequence co-localized with CD4
positive T cells and not with cd8
positive T cells suggesting that it was
a CD4 memory T Cell population that was
responsible for inducing this
Encephalitis triggered by pd1 treatment
so this was a very important finding
um because it's important to understand
the type of Adverse Events that can
happen due to immunotherapies and the
type of cell populations responsible for
induction of these Adverse Events
in this next example they want to
identify regulatory mechanisms of pdl1
mRNA although checkpoint therapies have
been extremely successful for a number
of malignancies we don't yet completely
understand how these immune checkpoint
receptors and markers are regulated at
the MRNA level
a francini and colleagues identified a
post-transcriptional regulatory
mechanism by which pd1 mRNA was
regulated in T cells they identified
that video and mRNA is transported via
microtubules and stress granules
before they are translated in the
cytoplasm
and to demonstrate that the utilized RNA
scope in combination with
immunofluorescence and uh showed us in
this image as you can see when the cells
were untreated uh you can see nice
tubulin staining and pd1 staining as
well as presence of pd1 protein in
yellow and a nice co-localization of the
MRNA and protein as you would imagine
and presence of intact tubular but when
the cells were treated with a
microtubule inhibitor you can see that
the uh
expression of mRNA is present as
expected the tubular marker is not
present anymore and also the pd1 protein
is very low or almost uh negligible in
expression suggesting that the amarna
was not successfully transported to the
cytoplasm and therefore did not get
translated efficiently
uh furthermore they also wanted to show
that this was happening via the stress
granules and used stress planning
specific marker g3bp1 antibody and
combined it with the pd1 transcript Pro
showing nice co-localization of the
first granule biomarker or sorry stress
granular marker with that of pd1 mRNA
suggesting that the
transport was indeed via stress granules
and
microtubules and is important regulatory
mechanism of the pd-1 MRNA
in this next example we'll see how this
workflow can be successfully used to
identify certain uh biomarkers and Drug
targets
in this particular example these
researchers are studying the Alzheimer's
disease are
model and
although we have made significant
advances in understanding Alzheimer's
disease we still don't understand the
association of
senescent cells with that of certain
physiological characteristics associated
with Alzheimer's disease including
cognitive impairment
and so these researchers wanted to
demonstrate uh the presence of these
sentencing cells in the amyloid beta
plaques found in the Alzheimer's prey
and so they used RNA scope p16 probe in
combination with the EB antibody to
demonstrate that p16 positive cells were
indeed present in these amyloid beta
plaques in this post-modern
they went a step further to show that
with 3D microscopy and imaging they were
able to study the 3D structure of the
plaque and showcase that the cells were
dispersed throughout the plaques the
sinuses are that p16 were present
throughout the blocks
next they also wanted to show that by
reducing a sentence in these animal
models they could potentially suppress a
neuropathology associated with
Alzheimer's disease and other
degenerative conditions
and so for that they treated these
Alzheimer's disease mice with
two phenolytic compounds that are FDA
approved that is two compounds that
would prevent senescence and when
they're treated these mice with these
cellulitic compounds you can see
compared to the vehicle the treated
sample had very low to no expression of
B16
suggesting that the sentences were
significantly reduced in these treated
models
next we're going to look at an example
of how this technique is specific enough
to look at the spatial organization of a
tissue and identify Niche specific
expression of irony biomarkers
uh here in this example they are
studying the role of cd19 positive
fibroblasts in differentiation and
homeostasis of the intestinal stem cells
as you all know intestinal stem cells
are important
as they've renewed the intestinal
epithelium which is important for a
healthy gut function
um
so what they did was they combined cd19
specific RNA scope probe with that of
various different
um antibodies for specific cell type
specific markers so in this first image
they've combined cd90 with uh gp38 which
is the fibrilla specific marker and as
expected there is nice collocalization
of this gp38 with the cd9 Positive cells
and this intestinal grips
they also combine cd90 with
um brdu which is an indicator of
proliferating cells and by using the RDU
antibody they were showing that
cd19 was in proximity to these um
epideial cells that were colorful
and finally they were able to show that
um cd19 was also proximal to hgr5
positive cells in the Crypt which are
potentially your intestinal stem cells
and so how does uh cd19 positive
fibroblasts actually exert their effect
on these stem cells and
um regulate differentiation of these
epithelial cells they were able to show
that by
um expressing
um or by secreting soluble factors Sigma
3 SEMA 3 they were the fibroblasts the
series 90 positive fibroblasts are
actually able to exert uh this impact on
the epithelial cells and promote
differentiation at homeostasis of these
um stem cells
and they were also able to show that
npr2 which is a marker for I'm sorry a
receptor for Sigma 3 was also found on
the epithelial cells of this intestines
so with this workflow of combining
arniscope with Amino fluorescence they
were able to establish the role of the
cd90 positive fibroblast and demonstrate
how they were able to regulate
differentiation of these stem cells in
the intestinal crypts
finally the last example I want to show
you how
in this first example let's study how
these researchers used
horoscope in combination with
immunofluorescence to study infection by
the rift valley wider The Rift Valley
fever virus is a zoonotic in fact as a
livestock
disease that can potentially have
zoonotic transmission to humans
we're not really clear on how this might
actually impact a pathology in debris if
it impacts the humans and those so these
researchers studied the infection of
this virus by using a rat model
they utilize specific RNA scope probe to
the viral RNA and combine that with IBA
1 positive antibody
to study uh infiltration of immune cells
post infection in this fat tree as you
can see compared to the uninfected cells
uninfected image
there is increased presence of the viral
mRNA and
immune infiltration post infection day
from 1 to day seven suggesting that that
can be potentially significant neural
information related to this viral
infection
uh with that I would like to transfer
the platform back to mathura
um and thank you for your attention
today
thank you Anushka for that excellent
overview of the need to detect RNA and
protein and showing us some great
examples of applicable research
questions addressed with this and with
that I would like to introduce you to
our reagents that enable these
applications
the new reagents in the form of the RNA
protein co-detection ancillary kit when
used with the new workflow will allow
researchers to simultaneously examine
cell type-specific gene expression and
identify cellular sources of secreted
proteins some of you may have already
tested certain antibodies and found them
incompatible with our RNA scope and base
scope assays our aim with this new assay
is to enable more antibodies to be
compatible with our assays and we will
see later some examples of key
antibodies that were previously
incompatible are now compatible with
this new workflow
the new RC is essentially contained
three parts the new RNA protein code
detection and celery kit which includes
the code detection blocker code
detection Target retrieval solution and
the code detection antibody diluent
which is also available as a standalone
item this kit has been validated with
our chromogenic red and Multiplex
fluorescent assays on both the manual
and the Leica platforms and also has
been validated with our base scope
assays along with this kit we would also
like to introduce you to the new
protocol where the key primary antibody
step is now performed right after the
target retrieval step following which we
go on to perform the rest of the RNA
steps
we then follow this up with the
secondary antibody to detect the protein
of interest on the same section and this
workflow has been designed to be
completed within two days with the
primary antibody intubation lasting
overnight as the break point
with this new integrated workflow
approach we have now enabled more
antibodies to be compatible with the RNA
protein code detection and reduce the
need for extensive screening for
compatible antibody clones resulting in
faster time to results
for those of you who may have tested the
sequential workflow before these new
reagents and workflows support
equivalent or better performance of
antibodies and also supports equivalent
sensitivity to ish only detection and
more Faithfully retain specificity of
the antibody in the IHC alone
in this slide I'm showing what a signal
from an IHC only run looks like in the
left pattern
and in the final panel on the right with
our integrated workflow and the new
pre-treatment reagents we can now rescue
the IHC signal and this in a sense makes
it easier to combine your antibody of
choice with rna-ish
to enable this compatibility our team
has developed some key reagents the
first of which is the target retrieval
solution
the target retrieval with the current
RNA scope and base scope assays has been
thoroughly validated and is intended for
use with the rna-ish assays alone
however in some instances these may have
impacted the protein detection
this new code detection Target retrieval
reagent has been formulated for improved
protein detection while maintaining
equivalent ish conditions or ish
detection
the second reagent is the co-detection
antibody diluent in our experience
certain commercially available antibody
diluents have negatively impacted RNA
staining as can be seen from the image
in the middle panel on this slide
this drove us to develop the new deluent
which maintains both rna-ish and IHC
staining
lastly to ensure no cross detection
between the two chemistries a blocker is
needed which is only required for the
manual chromogenic assays
the main difference between the previous
workflow and the new reagents in the
workflow is that with the sequential
workflow extensive prior optimization
was needed to ensure antibody
compatibility whereas now a
pre-validated list is no longer needed
and most IHC compatible antibodies can
now be combined with the rna-ish assay
foreign
T antibody shown here in the left panel
with standard IHC in the middle panel
with ish and IHC without the new
reagents in the protocol where we lose
the signal and in the right panel we are
now able to visualize both signals with
the new code detection reagents
and with that I would like to do a quick
recap if you're running our manual assay
you would need the ancillary kit and if
you're running this on the Leica
platform or the Leica Bond RX instrument
you only need the antibody diluent the
assay is compatible on the light carbon
RX are the 2.5 I say the red assay the
ls Multiplex fluorescent assay as well
as the base scope LS red assay
in the slide we create a reference for
the reagents you would need for each
protocol that we have validated with our
assays as an example if you're running
our manual assay red assay with the new
reagents and workflow you would need all
three reagents provided in the ancillary
kit please reach out to our excellent
support team to get help with getting
started with these new assays
now I would like to take you through
some examples of staining generated with
the new reagents and each of our
validated assays with IHC antibodies
in the first example here we show some
data with CD4 cd5 and fox B3 CD markers
are cell surface markers which are very
useful for the identification and
characterization of leukocytes and the
different subpopulations of leukocytes
CD marker specific antibodies have been
widely used for cell sorting
identification and cancer diagnosis
Fox P3 is a protein involved in immune
system responses and known to be a
master regulator of the regulatory
pathway in the development and function
of regulatory T cells these represent
fairly standard proteins utilized in
oncology research and shown here
combined with rna-ish can be used to get
more data out of precious samples the
samples shown here are tonsil head and
neck cancer and as you can see from the
panel on the right both RNA ish and IHC
signal is maintained with the new
workflow and reagent with a Leica red
assay
another example of staining here the
protein detection is performed using our
Green chromogen Giving a great contrast
on tissues where an alternate to the
brown dab is preferred perhaps data
tissue artifacts shown here are examples
of CD3 cd8 and Ki 67 antibodies in the
left panel as control IFC alone in the
middle panel combined with rna-ish
without the new reagents and workflow in
the right panel we observed optimal
signal detection with both the RNA and
protein this run was performed with our
manual assay
in this slide we show compatibility of
these antibodies in workflow with our
base scope assays on the Leica platform
moving on to fluorescent Asian if these
new reagents in workflow have also been
validated with our fluorescent Multiplex
fluorescent assays but we use the TSA
detection system to visualize the
signals shown as an example here are the
CD3 and cd8 antibodies on lung cancer
tissue with Control Pro ppiv for rna-ish
the antibody signal is in White and the
RNA scope signal is in red
here is an example of Triplex ish with
Ki 67 antibody with this new reagents
and workflow a key example of how you
can get much more data with more targets
and detect both RNA and protein on the
same slide
here we're highlighting some antibodies
specifically CD markers that may have
previously been incompatible in
combining with rna-ish and required
extensive screening and optimization
and lastly here are some more examples
of CD markers detected with the brown or
the green chromogen along with the red
ish signal
and with all that data I would like to
conclude and summarize today's
presentation in today's session we have
shown some key examples of how multiomix
profiling with single cell resolution
can be achieved with the new reagents
and workflow with this new ancillary kit
you can now incorporate rna-ish into
your existing IHC workflow to gain
deeper insights and preserve precious
samples this new reagent and workflow
have been extensively validated with the
red chromogenic and Multiplex
fluorescent assays on manual and the
Leica platforms and lastly we hope that
with this product and key research
examples we have shown in this deck
you're now able to utilize the power of
two technologies IHC and rna-ish to
answer your research questions
with that we will now address some
questions that we have coming through
thank you
thank you Madura and Anushka for that
informative presentation
just a quick reminder to our audience on
how to submit questions simply type them
into the Q a box and click on the send
button we will answer as many questions
as we have time for
our first question is
does the new code detection workflow and
reagents impact tissue morphology or the
RNA signal
thanks Maria this is Maduro and I can
probably take that question so
um yeah the short answer is no uh we've
actually really formulated or
reformulated some of the reagents as you
saw in our presentation today we have a
new traffic retrieval buffer we also
have a taken group kit to provide
specific um you know antibodies rules in
which we recommend that you dilute your
antibody of choice and that impact was
done in order to maintain both the
tissue morphology and also the RNA
signal as we're shown through the
various examples in the presentation
today we've shown that the signal
intensity of both the economy and
actually the protein is very well
maintained when utilized with this new
code detection workflow in conjunction
with the new leh is
uh great thank you
next question
can this workflow be used to identify a
clonal population of T cells
I can take that one Marie thank you so
much for that question and this is
really important because for Io
researchers we're trying to develop new
immunotherapies it's important to
identify specific population of T cells
and with our base scope assay in
combination with code detection you can
detect specific cdr3 sequences on T cell
receptors and then use antibodies again
CD4 or cd8 to identify that specific
population of T cells so with combining
our core detection assays with our base
co-partheids you will be able to
identify specific local populations of T
cells
great thank you and we have time for one
more question can the new code e
workflow be combined with fluorescent
assays
yeah that's a great question and the
answer is yes ABQ in fact if you were to
utilize these fluorescent vaccine that
we currently have available on the live
Club platform you can actually Flex
higher on the RNA Target so with our
fluorescent acid you have the capacity
to actually combine up to four RNA
targets of interest and then you can
additionally have the filter set you can
then add in your protein Target of
Interest as well
so typically if you have a standard for
a filter set what you could do is you
could combine three RNA targets and you
could utilize the fourth channel for
your antibody of Interest which
individuals Target your protein of
interest and that way you'll have a
three plus RNA assay and a one-flex
combined with the protein Target model
of Interest
so absolutely yes you can combined and
this new workflow with the fluorescent
acid and we have again demonstrated that
through some of the very beautiful
images and data sets that we've just
presented in the webinar
well great thank you so much
um do either of you have any questions
any final comments for our audience
all right well then a big thank you to
Madura and Anushka and thank you to our
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions we will
address questions we did not have time
for today and those submitted during our
on-demand period via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration this session webcast will
be available on demand after the event
that's all for this session thank you
for joining us and we hope you have
enjoyed this presentation bye for now
thank you